hello everybody um so it turns out i
catfished you i said i would do a
database case study and i totally lied
there are a couple of reasons for this
the first is that um
one they take a while to research and
i'm about to go on vacation for a week
so i don't really have time to do all
that research
two is that a lot of the things i was
seeing coming up when you know kind of
looking into like how cassandra for
example works the way it does we haven't
actually covered yet so i feel like i
should probably cover those first and as
a result of that um i feel like
uh the video i'm actually going to make
for right now is probably a better topic
i'm making a couple others you guys
don't uh don't have to miss my beautiful
face for too long and i'll try and do
those as scheduled uploads throughout
the week
but if i don't end up posting anything
else then probably you can expect the
next upload to be around
next tuesday wednesday or thursday
so with all this in mind i'm going to
talk about analytical databases because
i kind of skipped over these and
it's pretty cool how they work and
hopefully it'll be a pretty quick video
and easy to understand so let's get into
that all right so analytics databases
what's the point of them
uh the background is basically that uh
businesses often want to
run a bunch of internal queries on their
data that they have
in order to do things like a b testing
or other data science reasons to kind of
see what's working what's not working
and just get general aggregations over
their data
the point is though since these queries
take forever since they're going over a
ton of data you don't want to be running
them on your transactional database the
transactional database is the one that
you know like the client might interact
with or the client rights might go to so
instead what you'll typically do is have
a second database completely devoted to
analytics where all of your internal
analytics queries can be run on
and these work a little bit different
than transactions databases so we're
going to go over those
typically the process of taking the data
from your transactional database and
moving it to the analytics database is
known as an etl process which is
typically scheduled as a batch job which
means that once every time interval
we're going to be putting new data in
there and i'll go over what a batch job
is in a future video
okay so the first thing to note is stars
and snowflakes so stars and snowflakes
is basically the schema that we're going
to use in an analytics database it's not
actually going to look like the same
exact data that we have in our
transactional database
so as you can see
looking at this image here which i
lazily copied from the textbook that i'm
teaching from we have this fact sales
table so what is that this is a
centralized table with potentially
hundreds of columns and it's going to
have a ton of foreign keys to these
dimension tables which in turn may even
have more foreign keys to other
sub-dimension tables but the point is we
have one centralized table we can query
over and that central table has a bunch
of events which have foreign keys that
are relevant or they don't but either
way it allows you to get all the data
centralized in one place
so that is known as the star schema and
if there are a bunch of sub-dimension
tables it's known as a snowflake schema
okay so what's column-oriented storage
because this is a term that you may have
heard before so i'm gonna explain it so
transactions-based databases use
row-oriented storage they store the
entire content of a row together on disk
so it can be accessed sequentially that
means it's going to be faster when we
want the entire row this makes sense
because typically the row represents
something like say a user profile where
we want the whole thing at one time
however in an analytics-based database
we're using a fact table where we have
hundreds of columns and rarely we only
need a couple of them at a time so
what's actually better to do is store
all of the values of the columns
together in one file
that's the idea behind column oriented
storage
keep in mind that for each column they
need to be stored in the same order
otherwise we would say oh well the kth
value in this file is not the same row
as the kth value in this file so it
needs to be consistent between them okay
so let's talk about column compression
if each column has a ton of duplicate
values we can easily compress it so i'm
going to give an example imagine the
following column representing coding
proficiency out of 10. now as you can
see i'm clearly not one of these values
because i don't see any tens in there
but the point is we have three eights a
four a five four twos and a one so we
can actually do is first start by using
a bitwise encoding
a bitmap encoding is going to go and say
this for each value put a one if uh
that's where the value is equal to it
and a zero otherwise so for example for
value eight for you as you can see the
first three values in that column are
equal to eight hence there are ones
there and the rest are not hence there
are zeros
so we have these bitmap encodings which
are decently useful however we can
actually further encode these into run
length encodings so how are we going to
do that well i'm going to say okay for
value 8
look at that string of ones and zeros to
start there are zero zeros then there
are three ones then there are seven
zeros as you can see for value four
there are three zeros then one one then
six zeros and so on so as you can see we
can take all of these 10 integer numbers
and compress them into just three
numbers which is really great
okay continuing compression let's say
now that we wanted to actually do like
you know a query on some of those
columns
let's say we want to find all the rows
where column a equals 10 and column b
equals 20.
well what we could actually do is take
those two bitwise encodings for column a
equals 10 and column b equals 20 and do
a bitwise end on them so all the places
in the result of that where there's a 1
we know that the column a is equal to 10
and the column b is equal to 20.
also if we were just looking at
times where column a is equal to say 10
or 15 we could do a bitwise or between
the bitmap encodings for a equals 10 and
the bitmap encoding for a equals 15.
additionally compression is really great
because it allows more data to fit in
the cpu cache this means that we can go
ahead and run a tight loop without any
function calls on the on the data itself
and that is a lot quicker because it can
all fit in l1 cache and in addition this
can be parallelized more
okay furthermore if you want the column
sorted in a different way say we want
you know to sort by like a date key or
something
we can actually do this by having a
replica of our analytics database
where we have those columns all sorted
like that just keep in mind that every
column in that replica needs to be
sorted in the same way
and what this is really good for is a it
acts as an index if we want to do
efficient querying so say we're querying
by some like seconds since epoc now we
can easily find all the rows within a
given month but not only that it allows
for more column compression especially
on that date column because it means
that all of the the dates that are the
same are going to be right next to one
another and they can easily be
compressed
okay next writing to column oriented
storage so as i mentioned we have a
bunch of files on disk where all of the
columns are in sorted order so it'd be a
real pain in the ass to have to take one
value and just insert it in a sorted
file so what do we do instead well we
actually already have a data data
structure for this that we introduced a
lot earlier lsm trees so all of the
writes are actually going to an
in-memory tree buffer and then once that
buffer grows too big every once in a
while we're going to merge that lsm tree
into those sorted column files
additionally this means that reads get a
little bit more complex because they
have to check both the tree and the
column files and then merge those
accordingly
okay next we're going to move on to
something called materialized views
materialized views are essentially just
a precomputation or a caching of very
popular queries that might happen on the
analytics table so let's say i don't
know a sum of sales over the entire
thing
or maybe an average of you know
customers in a restaurant for every
single day
so the whole point is though that since
these are such common queries
the database is going to do them
automatically so that you can use that
result in subsequent queries
as opposed to recomputing it every
single time
so that's the pro here however the major
con is that now writes are going to take
longer since materialized views need to
be updated and in addition since these
are precomputed there's a little less
flexibility in using them than actually
just doing a raw query
the one thing to note with rights taking
longer is that this probably isn't a
huge deal because rights are generally
just done by batch jobs and we don't
really care how long it takes to get the
data into the data warehouse as long as
it's not like an obscene amount of time
you know it's not like the clients are
actually writing to the database so
having lower right throughput isn't
hugely important
okay next we have a data cube a data
cube is really just a special type of
materialized view that goes and
aggregates all the results over a
multi-dimensional table
this could either be two dimensions
three dimensions or so on and the
example that i'll show here i took
straight out of ddia which means that we
have the sales of every product id or
product sku on every single day in the
database so you can see we have 32 33 34
35 and onwards for product ids and then
the date key and as we can see all
that's going to have in the table is
just the sales of that product on that
day
and so we have a ton of pre-computations
here which can be really useful for a
variety of other queries
okay in terms of actually summarizing
what analytics databases are good for
it's really nice to have a separate
database for expensive read queries as
opposed to using the transactional one
that clients might use
additionally we can store our data even
better in a column oriented manner which
allows us to compress it and better
utilize cpu's l1 cache
finally when writing to column oriented
storage we can use an lsm tree as a
memory buffer
okay another thing is just that as a
reminder materialized views are
potentially very useful for caching by
pre-computing certain common queries at
the same time they do make right slower
okay i know this is a pretty quick video
but i'm just going to try and bust out a
few quick ones
i've done that before
in order to
give you guys something to watch while
i'm away and yeah i hope you guys all
have a great week and this one's
interesting